[Music]
and everything we said we'd be we just
traded for a suit cold in a
[Music]
DI underne the rolls up trees I will see
you where the ocean meets the
sky under your toes fire grows you are
ready for a different kind of life
you Sil and B the wind is cold you must
return to the
[Music]
W wind is C you must return to the
follow me down there's no one around lay
back and take your socks and shoes right
off that natural light is so damn polite
can make you feel just like you were
young again
[Music]
standing
underneath the rose of treams I can see
where the ocean meets the
sky under our clothes a fire grows we
are ready for this life of running w we
underneath the r of trees I will see you
where the ocean meets the
SK under your toes the fire grows you
are ready for a different kind of
life you sign and fall the wind is cold
you must to the
W S and Bing the wind is cing you must
a
[Music]
you turn toward me and look so we I've
never